[Musique]
du logiciel chapo guzmán avec ses oeuvres
[Applaudissements]
prix du jubilé de leo harlem
[Musique]
est le défi à l'État doit être
combattu avec toute la force de l'État
et c'est pourquoi nous devons combattre le
criminels parce qu'ici le seul propriétaire de
la ville ou l'unique propriétaire de la ville ou
le seul propriétaire de cet état est le
état mexicain
[Musique]
J'ai pu le démontrer et le documenter
plus de cinq ans de recherche
est que le gouvernement de Vicente Fox
comme celui de Felipe Calderón
ils n'y vont pas ils n'ont pas eu de guerre contre
trafic de drogue avant une guerre
contre les ennemis du chapó à
encourager le cartel de Sinaloa à
Il ressemble pratiquement à une affiche
hégémonique au Mexique pratiquement comme
un monopole de la drogue un monopole de plus
au Mexique en croyant absurdement que
avoir un seul signe un seul
l'interlocuteur pourra contrôler beaucoup
améliorer le trafic et le trafic d'armes
médicament
[Musique]
et joaquín guzmán parce que parce qu'il est le
aider les gens que le gouvernement devrait
commander la marche en est la raison
C'est à nous de dire au Seigneur pour
nous parce que ce n'est pas ce que nous ne voulons pas
aller plus loin car nous soutenons
parce que très bon monsieur pour nous très
bonnes personnes
[Musique]
Burger
d'el chapo guzman
[Musique]
Oh